اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انه الموسم
الانتخابي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ذلك الذي يشهد تجدد الجد في علاقه الرئيس
دونالد ترامب بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
جدل حمي وطيسه مع تهديد الرئيس بمقاضاته
وفيسبوك على خلفيه حجبه ما حسابات تابعه
لحملته الانتخابيه واخرى تعود لمقربين منه
كان عملاقا التواصل الاجتماعي الشهيران قد
منع اعاده نشر مقاله تتضمن معلومات عن نجل
جوزيف بايدن المرشح الديمقراطي فضلا عن
محطات سابقه شهدت ارتفاع منسوب التوتر بين
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي وترامب في غضون
ذلك من المتوقع ان يكون الكونجرس ساحه
لمعركه اخرى في حال نجاح الجمهوريين في
جلب المدير التنفيذي لشركه تويتر لجلسه
مسائله بخصوص الخطوه التي اقدم عليها
موقعه تقرير امال
والناس توقيته مثير هذا الجدل بين الرئيس
الامريكي دونالد ترامب موقعي تويتر
وفيسبوك تفجر قبل اقل من ثلاثه اسابيع من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد ان منع تويتر
وفيسبوك اعاده نشر مقال لصحيفه نيويورك
بوست حول اسره المرشح الديمقراطي جو بايدن
وجمد من اجل ذلك مؤقتا حسابات مرتبطه
بحمله ترامب ومنها الحساب الشخصي للمتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض كيلي ماكن نيني هذا هو
المقال مثار الجدل نشرته صح صحيفه نيويورك
بوست الاربعاء وضمنته ما قالت انها رسائل
الكترونيه كفيله بدعم الاتهامات التي كان
وجهها ترامب لبايدن نائب الرئيس اوباما
انذاك بشان مساعدته مجموعه غاز اوكرانيه
ينتمي ابنه هانتر الى مجلس ادارتها
مساعدتها على التهرب من تحقيقات بالفساد
وقد كان بايدن قد نفى جمله وتفصيله
التهابات ترامب لكن في نظر فيسبوك وتويتر
تبدو القصه اكثر تعقيدا وخاصه عند التمعن
في طريقه حصول الصحيفه على الوثائق تقول
نيويورك بوست ان مختصا في اصلاح الحواسيب
حمل الوثائق من جهاز كان يحتوي على رسائل
وصور ومقاطع فيديو شخصيه لهانتر بايدن وقد
سلمها لمكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه واحتفظ
بنسخه منها قدمها لعمده نيويورك السابق
قرب من ترامب رودي جولياني وكان جولياني
قد اتهم سابقا بممارسه ما وصفت
بالدبلوماسيين بايدن نحن هنا اذا في قلب
تفاعلات مع عرف بقضيه او فضيحه اوكرانيا
التي تفجرت اواخر العام الماضي وادت الى
محاوله محاكمه ترامب برلمانيا قبل ان
يبرئه مجلس الشيوخ اذاء لذلك اعتبر تويتر
ان السماح بمشاركه المقال عبر منصته سيشكل
انتهاكا لقاعده اساسيه وضعها وتتعلق بعدم
نشر اي معطيات شخصيه ومقر سنه من جهته
ابرز فيسبوك ضروره التحقيق في صحه ما
تضمنه المقال ملوحا بامكانيه ان يكون
مزيفه اثارت الخطوه غضب ترامب وتوعد
باللجوء الى القضاء من جهته قال السيناتور
الجمهوري تيد كروز ان اللجنه القضائيه في
الكونغرس تصدر مذكره لجلب المدير التنفيذي
لتويتر جاك دورسي للمثول امامها متهما
المنصه باساءه استخدام سلطتها المؤسسيه
واسكات
الصحافه كان الحظر المباشر لعناوين
الروابط وقمنا بتحديث سياستنا وباشرنا
اصلاح ذلك هدفنا هو محاوله اضافه سياق
والان لدينا القدرات للقيام بذلك وجاء رد
المسؤول الاول في تويتر بما بدا مقترحا
لحل قد يضع حدا لحيره المنصات الافتراضيه
حين يتعلق الامر برسم الحدود بين تعديل
المحتوى وبين ممارسه
الرقابه قد لا تتضح الان نجاعه ما اقترحه
تويتر لكن الاكيد ان مقال نيويورك بوست قد
اعاد الى الاذهان قضيه تسريب برسائل
الكترونيه للمرشحه الديمقراطيه هيلاري
كلينتون في انتخابات عام
2016 تعهد يومها القائمون على تويتر
وفيسبوك بمقاومه كل ممارسه قائمه على
القرصنه والتسريب ورغم كل خطوات التي بذلت
بدت قضيه مقال نيويورك بوست وكانها اعادته
ما الى المربع الاول والى الحيره ذاتها
ينضم الينا من واشنطن السيد سولا نيوس
الرئيس السابق للحزب الجمهوري في ولايه
ميشيغان ومن ماريلاند جويل روبين المساعد
او نائب المساعد الاسبق لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي لشؤون الكونجرس ومعنا من اسطنبول
السيد نبيل عوده الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه وسياسات امن الانترنت مرحبا بكم
جميعا وسؤالنا للسيد
اليوز تهديد الرئيس دونالد ترامب بجلب
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الى ساحات القضاء
الا يصيب في الصميم فكره حريه التعبير
بالاساس اليس هذا ترهيبا لمثل هذه
المنصات
ا ان هذه المنصات تحصل على ترخيص من
الحكومه الفدراليه
وهي منصات بث عام وبالتالي لازم ان تكون
مفتوحه ونزيهه فيما يتعلق بما ش وبالتالي
عندما يكون بنع موقع على حساب اخر هذا
يعني انكم تقومون بخدمه سياسيه وهذا
بالتالي هذا يعني انكم تساهمون بشكل نوعي
في حمله الديمقراطيين وبالتالي الرئيس
ترامب حملته يشعرنا بق شد هناك انحياز
ضدهم وذلك بمنع بعض المحتوى الذي ينشرونه
وهذا هو ما حصل
اليوم المقال او الماده الاعلاميه محل هذا
جدل حولها الكثير من علامات استفهام بشان
طريقه الحصول عليها مقرصنه او غير مقرصنه
او المعلومات التي وردت فيها سواء كانت
مغلوطه او غير مغلوطه هل يفترض تحت ستار
او تحت عنوان حريه التعبير ان تنهش وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي او الصحافه او الاعلام
اعراض الناس وسمعتهم بهذه
الصوره هذا بكي هو التحدي التحديات
تواجهها حريه تعبير اذ من يقرر ما هو
حقائق وواقع وما غير واقع هناك بت واضح
بشكل واضح هناك انحياز نحو الحزب
الديمقراطي والليبراليين والكثير من
المسائل وكثير من الامور التي يثيرها
الجانب الجمهوري غالبا ما تعتبر وتسمى
بانها غير صحيحه وغير دقيقه تماما لان
المحررين لا يتفقون مع هذا الراي ليس هذا
الطريق الجديد العمل اذا اردت ان تكون لك
منصه م فوحه وحريه تعبير الجميع فيجب ان
تسمح للجميع بالمشاركه وان ذلك يمكن ان
تقدم راي بديل ويمكن جانب اخر يقول لا
اعتقد بصحه هذا او هذا صحيح وبالتالي ليس
هناك اي طريقه ممكنه لاي منصه ان تقطع
كلام جانب واحد في حين انها تسمح لموقف
اخر من الجانب الاخر وهذه ليست الطريقه
الجيده للعمل في المحيط الفضاء العام الذي
كما حال في فيسبوك والتي التي تسيطر او
تقود وسائل
الاعلام سيد جويل روبن فكره حريه التعبير
المنصوص عليها في الدستور الامريكي واحد
ركائز الديمقراطيه الامريكيه يعني تستند
بشكل اساسي الى فتح الفضاء العام لكل
الاراء فاذا كان هناك مقال يحتوي على
معلومات مغلوطه او اراء معطوبه فان الرد
عليه يكون بمقال قابل او بجدل او بنقاش
عام اليس الحجب هو مناف لفكره حريه
التعبير او دع لا نبالغ في الامر لم يك
هناك منع كل ما حصل هو ايقاف موقت لهذه
المعلومات المزوره والمواد المقرصنه وهناك
سبب لذلك فالموقف الذي سمعناه من زميلي
الضيف الاخر هو نوع الموقف والتصرف اللي
يعني يدافع
عن تظليل الاعلام و وكما حصل في 2016 بحيث
ان المعلومات المظله يمكن ان تدخل في
تويتر وفيسبوك والمنصات الاخرى على حساب
حريه التعبير وحريه النقاش حيث ان حيث ان
الاجانب كانوا يقولون الامريكان ما ينبغي
ان يفكروا به في حين ان الامريكان كانهم
ان يناقشوا قضاياهم
بانفسهم بعيدا عن التضليل الاعلامي اذا ما
حصل امس توويتر قال توويتر قال هذه
معلومات مقرصنه والاف بي اي يحقق فيها
ويبدو انه قد انه قد نشرها او دفعها عملاء
روس وقاموا بقناعه معلومات شخصيه ان حمله
حمله ترامب تقوم بالكثير من الامور وتش
كثير لكن ل تمنع لكن فق ما نطلب منهم ان
يكونوا يتحلوا بالمسؤوليه وان يدعوا الى
المعلومات سيد روبن عذرا سيد روبن عذرا
على المقاطعه سيد روبن عذرا على المقاطعه
الرئيس دونالد ترامب يقول صراحه ان فيسبوك
وتويتر تحولا الى ذراع للحزب الديمقراطي
وانهما يقدمان خدمات كبيره بل ضخمه للحركه
الراديكاليه وهذا اكثر ما يهدد الامه
الامريكيه هذه المشاكل لا نسمع بها ولا
نراها الا مع الرئيس دونالد ترامب اليس
هذا دليلا عن انحياز تلك المنصات والاعلان
بوجه عام في الولايات المتحده لصالح
الديمقراطيين على حساب
الجمهوريين في الواقع هو طالما يشكو
ودائما يشكو من الحكام عندما لا يفوز في
المناقشه اذا كان لا يحب تويتر عليه ان
يترك هذه المنصه سب ال 8 ملايين متابع
لديه وهو دائما يقدم ارائه لهم ولم يمنع
ولكن ما نشهده في شركات التواصل الاجتماعي
ولاول مره ونشكرهم على ذلك انهم يتحملون
مسؤولياتهم للتاكد من الامريكان لا يجد
التلاعب بهم عن طريق التدخل الاجنبي
والتضليل الاعلامي علىعلى المستويات ود ان
اوضح شيء ان دونالد ترامب
نفسه قام بالكثير بنشر الكثير من سوء
المعلومات و تظليل المعلومات حول فيروس
كورونا وبت لم يمنع وهو يستطيع كل ماشاه
في هذا ليس بالديمقراطيه هو فقط غير سعيد
لان هجوم ضد ضد معارضيه بقياده وبدفع من
روسيا لم يسمح باستمرار
فيه سيد نبيل عوده مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اذا تباط في التحقق من صدق بعض
المعلومات الوارده فيها فانها تتهم
بتشويه سمعه المتنافسين في الحملات
والتاثير على نتائج الانتخابات واذا تدخلت
فانها تتهم بقتل حريه التعبير ما الذي
ينبغي على هذه المنصات ان
تفعل
والله هذا هذا سؤال كبير جدا واعتقد انه
لا يوجد احد يستطيع ان ان يضع اجابه
ملموسه وواضحه عن هذا الجواب لانه بالاخير
شاننا ام ابينا منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
تم الزج بها في المعترك السياسي ليس من
سنه وسنتين نحن نتكلم عن اكثر من اربع خمس
سنوات وحاولت منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
العمل قدر الامكان على ضبط الايقاع فيما
يتعلق في معضله ما بين سماح بحريه التعبير
من جهه ومنع انتشار الفيك نيوز الاخبار
الزائفه والتضليل من جهه اخرى المعادله جد
صعبه والمعادله جد خطيره لانه الحقيقه
التي نحن نتكلم عنها هي حقيقه سياسيه وهي
حقيقه جدليه بالاخير هناك يعني اي خصوم
غير متفقين حقيقه على حقيقه معينه وغير
متفقين على ميثاق شرف في التعاطي مع وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي او مع هذه الشركات
التكنولوجيه فلذلك الموضوع سوف يبقى يعني
خاضع للنقاش لانه اصل الفكره ليست بخبر
هنا او خبر هناك الاصل في بنيه هذه
الشبكات هي شبكات تواصل اجتماعي هي ديسنت
ليزد يعني غير مركزيه ولكن بنفس الوقت هي
غير يعني محاسبه على المحتوى الذي ينشر
بها فهي يعني في نوع من ال الطبيعه
الغائمه هنا فيما يتعلق بم منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي هل هي فقط منصات للتواصل بين
الناس ام
هي وسائل اعلام اذا كانت وسا تحولت الى ما
يجبه تحولت الى ما يشبه وسائل الاعلام مثل
الصحف ولكن بثوب حديث بثوب حديث يختلف
عنما كانت عليه وسائل الاعلام في الماضي
سيد سولا نيوزسياسة
المعركه ان صح هذا التعبير في الفتره
القصيره المتبقيه قبل الانتخابات في
الثالث من
نوفمبر الامر الشيئان في ان واحد تقريبا
عل اتذكر ان الجدل بدا حول مقال نيويورك
بوست وبت هناك اي دعايه سياسيه تقوم بها
وهذا ثالث اوسع جريده انتشارا وكان لديهم
مقال حول امكانيه تدخل هنتر بايدن في
الفضيحه التي حصلت في اوكرانيا وقد اغلقت
الصحيفه لان هناك من قرر ان هذا الامر
صحيح او لا فقط لاننا لا نتفق مع امر ما
ولا اجعله غير صحيح هذا هو التحدي اللي
نواجهه ليس هناك اي طريقه للتاكد ما هي
حقيقه وغير حقيقه لان كثير من الناس لديهم
تفسيرات مختلفه لمعنى ذلك
فسيد روشار الى موضوع الكورونا فايرس بعض
يقول هذه مشكله اكبر مما يعتقده
الاخرون لان اختلاف مع شخص شخص ما معك الا
يعني ان رايك رايك غير صحيح وبتك منصات
لتسهيل
البدل سؤالي جو روبين سيد جو روبين يستعد
الجمهوريون لاستدعاء ومسائله الرئيس
التنفيذي لتويتر في مجلس الشيوخ الذي
يهيمنون على الاغلبيه في ماذا سيتصرف
الديمقراطيون الديمقراطيين لا علاقه لنا
به لا حزب الديمقراطيه ولا
حمله بايدن قد اتصال بهم حول الموضع هذا
امر سخيف هذا مجرد هجوم سياسي علينا نحن
نعيش في عالم نجري ان التظليل الاعلامي
يعتبر وكانه امر حق للناس القيام به ولكن
ماذا عن الناس الذين هم الى جانب الحقائق
احن ايضا لدينا الحق ان الكورونا فايرس
خطيره وان ارتداء الكمامه يحمي الانسان
والتغييرات المناخيه موجوده حقيقيه هناك
حقائق تثبت ذلك والحقيقي ان الاف بي اي
مكتب التحقيقات
الفدرالي يحقق في المعلومات التي قدمت في
مقال نيويورك فوست لانه كانت عمليه او شيء
جا قد جاء من من روس وبالتالي نا ان نعيش
في عالم الحقيقه وانا سعيد ان شركات
التواصل الاجتما قرت طيب انا للاسف اطر ان
اقاطعك اطر ان اقاطعك مجددا لضيق الوقت
وسؤال للسيد نبيل عوده وارجو الاجابه باقل
من نصف دقيقه لو تكرمت الان وصل الصدام مع
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي الى اعلى
المؤسسات السياسيه في الدوله الامريكيه هل
تتوقع ان يحدث ذلك تغييرا في السياسات
الخاصه بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي واسلوب
عملها مجددا في المستقبل
هذا بكل تاكيد يعني هذا الموضوع احنا
شفناه منذ منذ سنوات المنصات التواصل
الاجتماعي تحدث بشكل مستمر في تحديثات
فيما يتعلق في جانب الخصوصيه او المراقبه
او ما الى ذلك وحتى رده الفعل السريعه من
من تويتر فيما يتعلق باخر حادثه من من
الغائها تماما الى نشرها لكن ضمن ضوابط
معينه دليل على انه هذه المنصات اصبحت
تراعي بشكل كبير جدا الاعتبارات السياسيه
المتعلقه بالتنافس بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين في امريكا و وغيرها من
مناطق العالم نعم شكرا جزيلا لك سيد نبيل
عوده الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه وسياسات
امن الانترنت كان معنا من اسطنبول واشكر
ضيفنا من واشنطن سولا نيوزي السابق للحزب
الجمهوري لولايه ميشيغن وكان معنا من
ميريلاند جويل روبين النائب المساعد
الاسبق لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون
الكونجرس شكرا جزيلا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام
هذه خاتمه ملفات الحصاد الى
[موسيقى]
k